(upbeat music)
- Rex is a really good boy.
- This is Pixel right here.
She's a little corgi.
And this is Tuk.
- This is Lou Reed, we call him Louie.
I actually hope he's gonna
go for the cheapest food,
but I feel like it's luck of the draw.
- He's not a picky eater at all.
He's literally eaten poop.
- They're gonna go cuckoo over being able
to actually eat something
other than their normal food.
- I've never seen him stop eating.
And I've never seen him
choose not to eat something.
(upbeat music)
(dish clanking)
(dish dropping to ground)
- Tuk went straight
for the expensive food.
Pixel immediately goes
for the medium grade dish.
Then goes for the very expensive stuff,
but seems to be very interested
in the medium grade food.
- So Rex just goes straight
for the expensive food,
no hesitation, he just
sucks it up super quick.
Then goes to the medium one,
then he slows down a little bit,
leaves some left and then
goes to the third one,
he's losing some steam,
but he's still going,
he's still chomping down, but yeah,
it seems like he really really
likes the expensive one.
(sighing)
- I'm unhappy.
I mean we named him Lou Reed.
We know he expects a lot.
He's gonna still live with
low to medium priced food.